welcome to the Medical Center I'm Bruce
Ackerman and I'm very pleased to
introduce Vernon Vulcan or for the
second of his four Simpson lectures on
Britain and Europe in a troubled world
today's lecture is called the Pandora's
box and the Trojan of course courses I
think I'm sorry for the singular of
Britain in Europe I hope you'll come
back again next week for two more
lectures I should note that we'll be in
room 202 on Monday not to be confused at
203 and in the auditorium on Wednesday
mr. bogden or is a professor of
government at the Institute of
Contemporary British history in King's
College in London in 2008 the Political
Studies Association awarded him the Sir
Isaiah Berlin award for lifetime
contribution to political science
suffice it to say that this distinction
was
that was very much deserved in my view
he is the leading British legal scholar
of his generation and I very much look
forward to his lecture on the current
[Applause]
well in my second lecture in my first I
admire the presence of Yale in asking me
to give lectures on brexit because today
is the very day as you probably know
that Theresa May is attending a summit
with the other 27 at which she will be
asking for concessions and help from the
other 27 and I think it perfectly
illustrates my theme today which was
first stated by Britain's foreign
secretary after the war in the first
Labour government who was Ernest Bevin
who the former trade union leader with a
very colorful turn of phrase and when in
in 1949 he was asked whether Britain
should join the Council of Europe which
he mistakenly thought would be a
supranational body but he said no he
said once you open that Pandora's box
you never know what Trojan horses will
fly out and these horses are I think
flying out today Europe has proved to
change the metaphor a poisoned chalice
for British governments since she first
applied to join the European communities
in 1961 and of Prime Minister Harold
Macmillan he had hoped that entry would
prove a good election cry for a
modernizing government against the labor
opposition which at that time was
Euroskeptics but two goals veto of the
British application in 1963 helped to
destroy McMillan's government and a goal
correctly predicted that Labour would
win the next elections his information
Minister alarm Poth
it records the goal of saying McMillan
vanishes he then sliced the air with the
back of his hand as pitiless as a Roman
Emperor turning down his thumb as though
denying a reprieve to a defeated
gladiator of course the same may happen
to Teresa may Edward Heath was the
conservative prime minister who took
Britain into the European community in
1973 after a second veto by de Gaulle in
1967 but in February 1974 he was
narrowly defeated in a general election
and in the case of a narrow defeat any
of a number of factors might be
responsible but one of them undoubtedly
was opposition to his policy on Europe
which was associated by many with rising
food prices the opposition Labour Party
was calling for a referendum on
Britain's membership and this was
supported by a former Conservative
Minister Enoch Powell who had won much
popularity particularly with
working-class voters for his attack on
high levels of Commonwealth immigration
Powell had opposed British entry and had
broken with the Conservative Party he
recommended a vote for labour so that
there would be a chance of taking
Britain out of the European community in
a referendum so Europe was undoubtedly
one cause of Heath's fall Margaret
Thatcher Heath successors Conservative
leader who became prime minister in 1979
gradually turned into a euro skeptic and
this was the lead to the resignation
from her cabinet of her deputy Sir
Geoffrey Howe in November 1990 House
resignation led in turn to a leadership
challenge a challenge which caused her
own resignation her successor John Major
declared that he wanted Britain to be at
the heart of Europe but his government
was riven in two by divisions over
ratification of the Maastricht Treaty of
1992 and a question of whether Britain
should adopt the euro these divisions
were a major cause of a landslide defeat
of the
in 1997 the next conservative Prime
Minister David Cameron who came to power
in 2010 proposed a referendum with the
aim of resolving the European issue once
and for all
but that referendum in 2016
resulted in the 52 to 48 vote to leave
Europe cameron immediately resigned his
successor to reason may has found brexit
to be the all-encompassing theme of her
government she too has had to cope with
divisions in her cabinet and her party
divisions reflecting a country that is
also deeply divided she too was
compelled to drink from the poisoned
chalice and has promised to resign as
soon as breakfast is resolved so Europe
has been responsible for destroying six
of the last seven conservative Prime
Minister's Macmillan Heath Margaret
Thatcher major Cameron and to resume the
only conservative Prime Minister since
1961 not to be destroyed by Europe was
Sir Alec douglas-home but he was Prime
Minister for only one year from 1963 to
four nor has the Labour Party proved
immune to the European virus during the
1970s indeed it appeared that labour was
even more divided on Europe from the
Conservatives the left wing of the party
was then hostile to membership and
pressed the party leader Harold Wilson
to concede a referendum in 1975 on
whether Britain should remain and after
Labour's defeat in the general election
of 1979 the left wing gained influence
and in 1983 general election which
Labour lost the party committed itself
to leaving the European community
without a further referendum and this
trend toward euro scepticism in the
party caused a split in 1981 a breakaway
by some of the leaders of the
pro-european faction including a former
Chancellor Roy Jenkins and a former
Foreign Secretary David Owen they formed
a new party the Social Democratic Party
fighting elections in alliance with the
pro-european liberals and eventually
merging to form the Liberal Democrats
more recently a small group of
Labour MPs has left the party to form a
new party with three conservative
remainders called
change UK and the rate one of the
reasons for that was they believe the
Labour leader Jeremy Corbyn was
insufficiently committed to the European
cause so Europe has proved toxic for
both political parties in Britain and
for British governments of both right
and left and nor as is clear has a
possibility of a disruption
yet been completed brexit after all is a
process not an event and a process
likely to continue for some years and
the reason why Europe has proved so
toxic is very simple it raises
fundamental problems of identity and
sovereignty it strikes at the very root
of the British conception of themselves
and seeks to answer the question is
being British compatible with being
European and that question is not one
that is bargainable the answer is either
yes or no unlike any economic issue you
are cast to come down on one side or the
other
now Britain did not join the European
community when it was formed in 1958 but
in 1961 British Prime Minister Harold
Macmillan made a decision to join a
decision characterized by his
predecessor Anthony Eden who was now
Lord
Avon as economically and I quote more
important than any decision since the
repeal of the Corn Laws which was in
1846 and on the political side it can be
more important than any decision we have
made in our history now Britain could
not ignore this new development
what shorter attitude be Britain had not
joined the Coal and Steel community but
had wished it well and it was after all
in Britain's interest if this new
development helped to ensure the peace
of the continent moreover the
strengthening of Western Europe would
help the defence of Western Europe and
enable it better to meet the Soviet
threat and that was one of the reasons
why post-war American administrations
were the Democrat or
public impressed for European unity
indeed marshal aid had been premise
Thanh the idea that the Western European
states would come together to organize
their economies and the American
administrator of the plan said that its
aim was and I quote to get Europe on its
feet and off our backs now a British
opinion therefore was positive towards
the European Coal and Steel community
when it was first formed but as it
developed European Economic Union was
seen to pose a threat both of power of
Britain in the world and to the British
economy and in his memoirs Harold
Macmillan as I said made the application
to join he said of moves towards
European integration in the early 1950s
I frankly hoped and believed that they
would break down if they were successful
it might be a short-term advantage
especially if it facilitated immediate
German rearmament but the long-term
future would be grim indeed there would
be a European community from which we
should be excluded and which would
effectively control Europe this was the
historic struggle in which we had been
engaged first against louis xiv then
against napoleon and twice in our
lifetime against germany germany was
weak now in the long run she would be
stronger than france so we might be
bringing about in 20 years time that
domination of Europe by Germany to
prevent which we had made such terrible
sacrifices twice within a single
generation and in March 1953 McMillan
lost the cabinet are we really sure that
we want to see a sixth power federal
Europe with a common army a common iron
and steel industry ending in a common
currency and monetary policy if such a
federal state comes into being
we'll it in the long run be in our
interest whether as an island or as an
imperial power will not Germany
ultimately control this state and may we
not have created the very situation in
Europe to prevent which in every century
since the Elizabethan age we have
thought long and bitter wars and when he
was Prime Minister Macmillan tried to
dilute the European community into
something intergovernmental he proposed
in place of it a free trade area a plan
for free trade in industrial goods
between the seventeen free powers of
Western Europe agriculture would not be
included so there'll be no common
agricultural policy
and no common external tariff so the
free trade area would not affect British
imports of cheap food from the
Commonwealth and with no political
implications such as ever closer Union
but for these very reasons the free
trade area did not appeal to the sixth
in the European community because with
free trade in manufactures but not in
agriculture
it would mean British Goods could enter
the industrial markets of the continent
tariff free while the produce of
continental farmers would not enter the
British market tariff free and the
opposition of the free trade area was
led by France even before the goal came
to power in 1958 but French hostility
became even stronger once he was in
power in 1958 and it was the Gould who
put an end for negotiations and that was
a very clear sign that Britain was
losing the leadership of Europe she was
no longer as with the discussions on the
Coal and Steel community which I talk to
Burke on on Monday no longer being asked
to take a position of leadership in
Europe but the leadership now seemed to
be with France Britain was seeking
favours which were not being granted she
was in the position which de Gaulle said
no country should ever be in of being a
supplicant she was a supplicant when she
sought entry into the European community
just as she is now a supplicant as she
seeks to leave it now after the failure
of the free trade negotiations britain
took the lead in organizing her own free
trade air with six other countries not
in the european community three
Scandinavian countries with together
with Austria Portugal and Switzerland
freed European free trade association or
after in short and that had free trade
in industrial not agricultural goods
with no common external tariff and no
pretensions to political unity so Europe
was now divided between two
organisations the European community of
the six and the European free trade
association of the seven and it didn't
take long for people to say that Europe
was now at sixes and sevens but the
seven were in a weak peripheral position
while the six comprised a strong centre
since it contained the major European
powers with the exception of Britain so
Britain was outside the major power
grouping in December 1959 Harold
Macmillan wrote his foreign secretary
for the first time since the Napoleonic
era the major continental powers are
united in a positive economic grouping
with considerable political aspects
which though not specifically directed
against the United Kingdom may have the
effect of excluding us both from
European markets and from consultation
in European policy six months later in
the privacy of his diary Macmillan began
to began to confide that Britain might
have to join he wrote in his diary in
July 1960 shall will be caught between a
hostile or at least less and less
friendly America and a boastful powerful
Empire of Sharla Manya now under French
and later bound to come under German
control is this the real reason for
joining the common market if we are
acceptable it's a grim choice but in
1961 two years after the 1959 general
election in which no party had suggested
we join
M'Lynn made that grim choice and applied
to join the Labour opposition opposed
him but the Labour government in 1964
also came to apply in 1967 and was also
vetoed by de Gaulle since then every
single Prime Minister has thought that
our future lay with Europe and no Prime
Minister until to resume has thought
that we should leave the European Union
but she voted remain in the referendum
and she is leaving because she believes
she's being instructed to do so by the
people in a referendum so the key
question is why did both parties change
their mind on Europe as one great
difference between the late 50s and the
early 60s Hort time the huge loss of
British self-confidence which had begun
with the Suez Crisis which showed that
Britain was not as powerful as many
thought and she could not carry out a
major military intervention against the
wishes of the United States and
certainly not a superpower Macmillan
became Prime Minister Lee after suez
crisis and tried to repair relations
with the medaka but they wanted Britain
to join and it was clear the
Commonwealth was not a power grouping
whatever else it was and was just as
liked to oppose Britain as to support
her during the Suez Crisis only
Australia and New Zealand supported
Britain and the rest of the Commonwealth
were opposed and Canada particularly
strongly in the old Commonwealth the new
commonwealth members in asia and africa
led by india were particularly
environmentally opposed nor was the
commonwealth an economic unit some of
its members had established
protectionist policies of their own and
there was little chance of getting
cohesion from the commonwealth then in
1960 britain suffered to further blows
to her prestige her position as an
independent nuclear power was put into
question when the Blue Streak missile
was cancelled and in future she would be
dependent on America for delivery of the
missiles needed for her nuclear weapons
so the policy of preserving her great
power status by maintaining an
individual and independent I beg your
pardon independent
deterrant was coming to be severely
qualified and then the summit conference
which Macmillan had striven to arrange
and which he hoped would ameliorate the
Cold War collapsed when the Americans
refused to apologize for sending spy
planes in the Soviet territory one which
was shot down and the Russians refused
to reconsider their decision to abandon
the summit and Britain's problems were
well summarized in a famous or as many
British people would say no tourist
speech made by the former American
Secretary of State Dean Acheson at West
Point in 1962 when he said Britain has
lost an empire and not yet found a role
perhaps that's still true he went on to
say the attempt to play a separate role
that is a role apart from Europe a role
based on a special relationship with the
United States a role based on being a
head of the Commonwealth which has no
political structure or unity or strength
and enjoys a fragile and precarious
economic relationship by means of the
Sterling area and preferences in the
British market that role is about to be
played out
Great Britain attempting to work alone
and to be a broker between the United
States and Russia has seemed to conduct
a policy as weak as its military power
and at that time there was a rather
unkind satire of Macmillan talking to
President Kennedy and President Kennedy
was listening to Macmillan and Macmillan
said that Britain was trying to be an
honest broker and Kennedy said he
thought he could think of no country
which was more honest and Macmillan in
his satire said there was no country
which was broken
and a Justin speech caused a great deal
of resentment in Britain but that may be
because it was articulating a painful
truth and Europe then was coming to seem
a way out of Britain's strategic
dilemmas but also out of our economic
dilemmas the 1950s had seen an age of
affluence and the ruling conservatives
had won the general election of 1959
with an increased majority on the slogan
life's better with the Conservatives
don't debt labor ruin it but soon
afterwards doubts set in because it
seemed the six member states of the
European community were enjoying a
higher rate of growth than Britain and
there was a reappraisal of British
economic policy at this time involving a
greater degree of economic planning and
an attempt to reach an agreement with
the unions on wages policy and entry
into Europe seemed an important part of
this reappraisal because people argued
that by providing competition in a
larger market it could help rejuvenate
British industry however all this meant
that Britain was entering Europe for
quite different quite different reasons
from those of the original six the
original six shared the view of Robert
Schuman the French Foreign Minister that
the European powers shared a common
destiny Britain did not or only
partially accepted that view
she joined because she had run out of
alternatives she was desperately seeking
to avoid further slipping down in her
international position she joined if you
like on the basis of a cost-benefit
analysis but when Harold Macmillan had
sought to join he encountered
fundamental difficulties difficulties
which probably have never been resolved
and the essence of the problem was one
of fitting Britain into a continental
system whose assumptions about
constitutions politics and economics was
so different from those held in Britain
the most fundamental problem perhaps was
that of fitting a constitutional system
based on the
Parliament and the absence of a codified
Constitution into one based on a written
constitution of separation of powers and
subordination of the legal systems of
the member states to superior system of
European law a system that an Italian
political scientist sir Joe fabrini has
called a compound Republic a system of
government that some parallels perhaps
to that of the United States and while
perhaps the prospect of the profit of
the American system of division of
powers is James Madison the prophet of
the British system of undivided
sovereignty is Thomas Hobbes and this
conflict between the two conceptions of
government was always to be something
very fundamental that the British people
never accustom themselves to there were
in addition interrelated problems
relating to agriculture and the
Commonwealth the basic problem
concerning agriculture was that
Britain's system of protection had
evolved in a quite different way from
that of the continent Britain had a
small agricultural sector comprising
about three and a half percent of her
economy France agriculture comprised
about one-fifth of the economy Italy a
quarter Germany an eighth and because of
her small agricultural sector Britain
could not meet her food requirements
domestically and relied much more than
continental countries on food imports
most of these came from the old
Commonwealth particularly Canada
Australia and New Zealand and since 1932
there had been a system of Imperial
preference by which Britain benefited
from cheap food and the policy of cheap
food had been a fundamental principle in
Britain since the repeal of the Corn
Laws in 1846 and seen many argue the
basis of her earlier prosperity
agricultural support given by the
British government was done not through
tariffs
but by means of subsidies to domestic
agriculture paid for by the taxpayer
continental countries adopted a quite
different method of agricultural support
they supported it not through the
taxation system but in the form of
guaranteed prices which meant that their
food prices were higher than those on
the world market in Britain the taxpayer
paid for agricultural subsidies on the
continent the consumer paid and this is
very fundamental in the negotiations
because the conservative and Catholic
parties of the right in Germany Italy
and France who in power for much of the
post-war period relied heavily on the
votes of peasant farmers who sought
subsidies but resisted high direct
taxation and during the early 1960s the
percentage of public revenue raised from
direct taxation was over twice as much
in Britain as in France and Italy to
subsidize the welfare state
now obviously the European community had
embraced the continental rather than the
British system of agricultural support
they would hardly be willing to agree to
Britain maintaining higher subsidies for
her farmers combined with lower prices
in the open market for Commonwealth
producers at the expense of agricultural
exports from Europe and the communities
Common Agricultural Policy which still
exists was based on two principles the
first was that all members should be
treated equally and this meant that
Britain could not be given preferential
or different treatment the second was
that members of the community should be
given preferential treatment as compared
with outsiders and that included the
commonwealth food producers would you
excuse me I think there wasn't glass
drink franc my voice is running out that
I will take a swig it will excuse
so the first principle all members
should be treated equally
the second principle is community
preference members of the community be
treated better than those outside the
Commonwealth could not be given
preferential treatment so the common
agricultural policy of Europe which
didn't exist until a major source of its
spending was based on guaranteed high
prices for agricultural products in
Europe with a common external tariff
against agricultural products produced
elsewhere to prevent undercutting now
this would cause problems for Britain or
thank you very much indeed very kind not
only for economic reasons but for
sentimental reasons because of course
thank you very much because people
remembered the support that Commonwealth
had given to Britain during two world
wars and during the difficult years of
austerity afterwards and it was one of
the main reasons why the Labour Party
came out in opposition to British
membership in the early 60s and the
Labour leader Hugh Gaitskell was much
influenced not only by Canada Australia
and anning but by the views of the
Indian High Commissioner who said the
consequence of entry would mean applying
a common external tariff to these Asian
Goods and the old Commonwealth important
too and Hugh Gaitskell said to go in on
bad terms which really meant the end of
the Commonwealth would be a Steff I
think we would regret all our lives and
to which history would not forgive us so
it meant that cheap food imports from
the Commonwealth would have to end and
the continent said perhaps not
unreasonably why should we make special
provision for New Zealand farmers who
are richer than Italian or French
peasants and they would not therefore
have undercutting of community
agricultural goods so instead of
preference from the Commonwealth there
would be a reverse preference against
the Commonwealth it would involve
putting Imperial preference on its head
and giving preference to Europeans
instead and it would mean therefore the
end of Britain traditional cheap food
policy in place of cheap food from the
Commonwealth we
be importing more expensive food from
the continent and instead of the
taxpayers subsidizing just food produced
in Britain the British consumer would be
and indeed still is subsidizing food
from wherever it was produced in the
community Britain or other member states
that would mean a rise of course in the
cost of living now supporters of entry
said this will be compensated for by
access to British industrial goods well
they'll have in the markets of the six
but of course the rise in the cost of
living would cause wage demands
increasing the price of British
industrial products and British
industrial products would face increased
competition from continental Goods could
they cope with that competition what was
clear was the benefits to British
industry was somewhat speculative and
difficult to quantify but the rise in
the cost of living would be certain and
immediate the position for Britain
worsened I think not accidentally while
the early negotiations were going on
because during the pitted negotiation
the six founding members came to an
agreement on budgetary policies and that
agreement answered the question what is
to happen to the levies collected on
agricultural products and the British
hoped these would remain with a member
state that collected them but that was
not a solution reached by the six they
said if national economies benefited
from the levies there would be an
incentive to import food from outside
rather than from within the community
therefore the whole of the product the
levies should go to an agricultural
guidance and guarantee fund in Brussels
which would pay it out to producers to
subsidize agricultural exports it would
then be redistributed to the Member
States in proportion to the size of
their agricultural sectors that of
course would very much disadvantage
Britain again because she had a small
agricultural sector France which
produced a high proportion of her own
food would pay small levies
Britain would pay large levies so she
would be financing in effect continental
food imports at higher prices at the
expense of those from the Commonwealth
and money which had previously gone to
Australia Canada and New Zealand would
now go to less efficient farmers on the
continent so it's hardly surprising that
four years after we entered the
community that is in 1977 it was found
that Britain was the second largest net
contributor to community funds after
Germany although at that time only two
member states had a lower level of
national product per head and this
problem of Britain's excessive net
contribution caused endless trouble from
the time Britain entered the community
in 1973 it did not come anywhere near to
resolution until Margaret Thatcher
succeeded after difficult negotiations
in getting a rebate for in 1984 perhaps
it's not been fully resolved even now
and cannot be until the Common
Agricultural Policy is abolished which
would not be countenanced by the other
member states now these problems stemmed
in large part from the different aims of
the negotiators Britain could easily
have said had she she could easily have
said we accept the Treaty of Rome the
founding document of the Constitution
and we are prepared to sign on the
dotted line but no British government
could do this British governments were
hoping to amend the rules so that they
were more in line with British interests
in a negotiation but the founding
members of the community sought by
contrast to preserve the rules and the
institutional structure which they had
so painfully created they were not
prepared to alter the fundamentals they
said they had achieved after complex
negotiations an agreement in the Treaty
of Rome
Britain had not wished to take part in
the process now she wanted the rules
altered to suit her interests so it was
understandable if they took the view the
package should not be untied it was
written to decide whether she wanted to
accept the
package or not there hope she would but
would not despair if she did not so the
British took the view and those who have
been following the brexit negotiations
will realize she takes the same view now
but Britain was involved in a
negotiation and that the solution should
lie as it were midway between the two
sides as often happens in a negotiation
but the continent said the problem is
simply to fit Britain into a system
which already exists
and that meant Britain would pay a high
price to enter now the British be kept
perhaps because of their imperial past
intended I think at this time perhaps
some still do theydo tended to perhaps
take the view that British interests lay
at the centre of the world and other
countries not only in Europe but also
the u.s. were under a duty to help
Britain out of any difficulties that she
found herself in and they are then taken
by surprise to discover that not that
the European Union and for that matter
the American Congress also that these
institutions are not charitable
institutions that they actually have
interest of their own which may not
necessarily coincide with those of
Britain and perhaps as I say that is the
product of the imperial past but that so
called an inward negotiation when
Britain entered and the word negotiation
now when Britain is leaving this word is
something of a misnomer and it was
certainly been a misnomer for all of the
countries which have sought to enter the
European Union since its foundation
because what happens is that the
Europeans work out their position and
present their proposals to the candidate
member it is then for the candid member
to decide whether it wishes to join or
not on that basis if it does not wish to
join it will withdraw her application
and there won't be too many tears on the
part of the Europeans the same is true
in
dentally it seems me of the brexit
so-called negotiations the Europeans
work out their proposals and present
them to a departing state which then has
the alternative either accepting them or
of leaving without a deal something
which many economists certainly think
would have a disadvantageous consequence
if you want to join a Tennis Club
you cannot quibble about the rules if
the tennis club exists if you decide to
leave the club but still want to play on
the tennis courts that is trade with
Europe on a favorable basis you are not
in a strong position to negotiate if you
have decided to leave the Tennis Club
and that perhaps sums up Britain's
position now and also in 1961 when she
tried to join the European community and
there was a rather comic episode in 1967
which illustrates this under the Labour
government when the Prime the Labour
Prime Minister Harold Wilson and the
foreign secretary George Brown came to
see president de Gaulle to try and sort
things out with him and overcome his
veto it didn't begin very well because
George Brown the Labour foreign sectors
are all a volatile character and he
called General de Gaulle Charlie which
didn't please him much but he then he
then said let us get down to brass tacks
about the problem of Europe and
president de Gaulle said I do not
understand what you mean France is in
the European community and has no
problem with it
Britain is outside and wishes to join
and that is her problem so they didn't
get very far with that particular
negotiation it is fair to say but once
Britain was in the European community
those aspects which were not
particularly favorable could be
renegotiated for example in the
Fontainebleau agreement of 1984
negotiated by Margaret Thatcher which
modified Britain's financial
contribution and indeed when Britain
joined the Common Agricultural
policy was the main common policy of the
community absorbing around 75% of its
budget since then it had been radically
reformed and now absorbs around 33% of
the budget due to fall to around 30% the
main element of the budget is now aids
the ex-communist member states in
Central and Eastern Europe which absorbs
around 35% of the budget and this in
turn means there's no longer the same
gross mismatch between benefits and
contributions of their walls because
most of the richer member states are now
net contributors and nevertheless the
Common Agricultural Policy still does
impose an unfair burden on British
taxpayers and consumers now in the 1960s
survey evidence seemed to show that
public opinion was broadly supportive of
the application but this was to some
extent misleading because when faced
with specific terms the public became
skeptical if not downright hostile for
example a poll carried out in 1966
showed that well over two-thirds
savoured entry but when asked would you
still favor entry if he put up the price
of food by two shillings in the pound
only 39% for in favor and if entry meant
weakening our ties with the Commonwealth
only 25% for in favor if it meant that
New Zealand agriculture and I quote
would suffer quite a bit
only 23% were in favor of macmillan said
when he applied to join it was a turning
point but it was not a decision for
europe in the sense of a wholehearted
commitment british government's sought
the minimal adjustment possible now
supporters of british entry argued well
we could have got better terms if we had
applied earlier which is perhaps
disputable but what is clear as I've
said is that very few believed in the
policy of sharing common destiny with
the continent and the official historian
of Britain's relations with Europe had
discovered and I quote one common thread
every one of Britain's Prime Minister's
has believed essentially in an
intergovernmental
European community and he said with rare
exceptions the decision to seek
membership of the community and the
subsequent experience of that membership
were affairs of the head rather than the
heart now it is ironic that Britain's
conception of the future of Europe
seemed to have something in common with
the gorlice conception because every
British Prime Minister would have agreed
with de Gaulle in rejecting the idea of
a supranational much less a federal
Europe they agreed that Europe should
develop as a Europe of states what de
Gaulle called a yacht they said tar
apparently did not use the phrase Europe
dip that tree and Macmillan tried to win
to go around to this view in negotiation
in November 1961 he said at first he and
his friends in the European movement had
met with great difficulties because they
had to battle against the ideas of the
Federalist movements which were
unrealistic and had no appeal in this
country and that was an exaggeration
they were hardly any Federalists in
Britain been all now but Macmillan went
on now progress was possible towards the
United Europe based not on
integrationist ideas but on confederal
ideas but although the British and
French agreed on a Europe of states they
could not agree on whether Britain
should be part of it
and part of the reason for this indeed I
think the main reason was the goals fear
that have Britain entered the community
before the Common Agricultural Policy
was finalised she would seek to sabotage
or diluted indeed which she tried to do
and then French agriculture would be
ruined and as the goal told his cabinet
France would face riots in Paris she had
previously done in Algiers but perhaps
even more fundamental was a British and
French had quite different conceptions
of Europe for the goal the central
concept was independence a European
Europe a separate power bloc independent
from the United States at a press
conference in 1967 he said the idea the
hope which from the beginning led the
six continental countries to unite was
undoubtedly to form an entry that an
entity I bigger pardon
that would be European in all
spec's that is to say it would not only
carry its own weight in trade and
production but it would be capable one
day of dealing politically with anyone
for its own sake and on its own
in view of the special relations of the
British with America together with the
advantages as well as the liabilities
arising for them out of these relations
in view of the existence of the
Commonwealth and of the privileged
relations they have with it it is not
possible to see how the policies could
merge unless either the British resumed
complete freedom of action particularly
with regard to defence or unless the
peoples of the continent gave up the
idea of ever building up a European
Europe de Gaulle said the British must
choose between Europe and America and
that was a choice which the British did
not want to make because from Macmillan
by contrast with de Gaulle the key
concept was not independence but
interdependence which was a light motif
of his administration and he sought to
put Britain the sense of an
interdependent Commonwealth and an
interdependent Western Europe while
retaining all the rights of a sovereign
state in nuclear defense he saw Britain
as a bridge like every British Prime
Minister except for Edward Heath a
bridge between Europe and America for
this for the goal meant diluting the
concept of a European Europe now
Macmillan tried to win over the goal
with the idea of nuclear cooperation
between the two countries
but this gift was not in McMillan's
control it required American agreement
to share nuclear secrets with France as
she already did with Britain but in any
case the goal was not interested he was
determined to develop a genuine French
nuclear deterrent a force de frappe not
dependent on America for its means of
delivery in December 1962 Macmillan
having at last secured American approval
offered the goal the Polaris missile but
France would if she accepted have to
rely on American nuclear warheads
because she had no nuclear-powered
submarines to deliver the missile no
unlike Britain could
manufacture nuclear warheads so the
discussions revealed a fundamental
difference between Britain and France
which Macmillan did not wholly
comprehend from that millon the British
nuclear deterrent was aimed at
strengthening interdependence with
America but for France it was to help
her become more independent of America
and the Cuban Missile Crisis of October
1962 confirmed the goals view that
America did not regard Europe's defence
as a first priority and that she might
prefer a bilateral settlement with the
Soviet Union at Europe's expense the
goal referred four times to the Cuban
Missile Crisis in the press conference
in 1963 in which he pronounced his veto
on British entry into the communities so
ironically Britain's offer of nuclear
collaboration made the goal even more
determined to reject Britain and it made
the goal think that Britain was weak
being dependent on America and after his
meeting with Macmillan at ranvier in
December 1962 the French president told
his Minister of Information England back
is broken in December 1962 the goal
thumbed up his objections to British
entry at a meeting of his concede a
ministry he made it clear that
agriculture was fundamental
if Great Britain and the Commonwealth
enter it would be as if the Common
Market had dissolved within a large
free-trade area always the same question
is posed but the British don't answer to
please the British should we call into
question the Common Market and the
negotiation of the agricultural
regulations that benefit us all this
would be difficult to accept Britain
continues to supply itself cheaply in
Canada New Zealand Australia etc what
will we do with European and
particularly French surpluses if we have
to spend five hundred billion francs a
year on agricultural subsidies what will
happen if the Common Market can no
longer assist us these eminently
practice
called questions he said should not be
resolved on the basis of sentiments
Harold Macmillan is melancholy and so am
i we would prefer McMillan's Britain to
that of Labor and we would like to help
him stay in office but what can I do
except to sing him the Edith Piaf song
no Clara Pamela don't cry my lord or I
think the actual song is Alan moves on
me Lord go away the goals Vito left
Harold Macmillan in despair all our
policies at home and abroad are in ruins
European unity is no more French
domination is the new and alarming
feature our popularity as a government
is rapidly declining Britain's position
declined in 18 years from being the
undisputed leader of Europe to that of a
supplicant France a country ruined by
the war whose recovery had been
dependent on Britain and America was now
the dominant power on the continent it
was a stunning reversal of influence but
the goal was unmoved strange times
gentlemen he told his consider Minister
when one cannot say without provoking I
do not know what kind of a hullabaloo
that England is an island and that
America is not Europe when a former
French Prime Minister Paul hey no wrote
to the goal accusing him of ingratitude
in view of Britain's role as an ally of
France in two world wars he received in
reply an empty envelope on which was
written on the outside redirect to
Agincourt some or waterloo belgium our
next president of france Georges
Pompidou was supportive of British entry
but he made it clear it would require a
profound change in British thinking she
must become what the French called
community a community preference
President Pompidou said lay at the heart
of the
European project because the Europeans
wanted to encourage members to trade
with each other rather than the outside
world so the Common Agricultural Policy
was an essential part of the European
project but the British wanted a free
trade area
he said that could not be just that and
part of the purpose was as President
Pompidou told Edward Heath the
preservation of the French countryside
and way of life and for the Christian
Democrat partisans the continent it was
vital to ensure the preservation of the
small farming community members of a
politically sensible and moderate class
hostile to socialism so Europe should
not on their view then become a wholly
urban civilization a strong agricultural
sector therefore was necessary to
preserve the equilibrium of French
society so for the Christian Democrat
parties of the continent the Common
Agricultural Policy was not just a piece
of institutional machinery but a vital
part of that philosophy now all this was
no doubt a very fine statement of
principle but of course it suited French
national interest which was not
necessarily the same as Britain Bismarck
Germany's Chancellor in the latter half
of the 19th century is supposed to have
said I have always found the word Europe
in the mouths of those politicians who
wanted from other powers something they
did not dare demand in their own name a
comment that was to be cited very often
by Margaret Thatcher the Common
Agricultural Policy was buttressed in
1966 by Frances interpretation of what
was called the Luxembourg compromise
which president de Gaulle insisted upon
and this compromise declared that where
a Member State believed that a vital
national interest was at stake it could
veto any new development in the
community Britain was in principle
sympathetic to this since she was
concerned at the implications of
majority voting in Europe and the loss
of sovereignty which that involved but
the effect of the compromise then was to
freeze further
of the community so the Common
Agricultural Policy which was in
France's interests could not be altered
without French consent while other
common policies which might perhaps be
in Britain's interests could be vetoed
by any other member state Britain for
example at hoped for a European regional
policy to help her depressed regions but
that would not be possible unless the
only other members agreed to it and they
wouldn't do so because they would have
to pay for their own budgets to help
Britain's depressed regions and the veto
was to remain until 1986 when it removed
with a single European Act ironically at
the insistence of the British government
led by Margaret Thatcher in his memoirs
Edward Heath calls a chapter in which he
discusses Britain's entry fanfare for
Europe he regarded entry he said as a
wonderful new beginning and a tremendous
opportunity for the British people but
few share that optimism and indeed it's
easy to overestimate not only din thoose
II Azzam but even the knowledge of the
British people about Europe around 15
years ago I heard a European labour MP
give a lecture sorry a pro-european
Labour MP a British Labour MP was
pro-european give a lecture in which he
reported his experience of canvassing in
his north of England constituency and a
man approached him and said you're a
good chap
I shall vote for you but I don't like
all this Europe I don't think we should
join the MP gently reminded him that we
have been a member of the European
community European Union for over 30
years
the reply was well isn't that typical of
politicians they never tell you anything
now and the gold Prime Minister George
Pompidou who later became president had
written at the time of the first French
veto in 1963 the difficulties were the
British application were not merely
technical but what he called dumb
problem two concepts young men do maths
a comma S on a veneer problems connected
fundamental problems and these difficult
to put a dog Britain from the time she
joined she joined us an unfortunate time
when the truant glorias the 30 year boom
was come
to an end after the Yom Kippur War and
the quadrupling of oil prices would led
to reaction by the Arab states to
continued Israeli occupation of their
territories and this also undermined
European solidarity since some members
of member states supported the Israelis
while others supported the addams so the
European idea was now coming to be
associated with Europe with economic
difficulties it might have been
different had we joined in 1963 as
Macmillan wanted and public opinion was
now recoiling after the second veto in
1967 understandably after two rebuffs
and the high point of support for Europe
came in 1966 by 1970 70% were against
while 80% believed that prices would
rise more rapidly if Britain joined and
62% wanted a referendum before Britain
joined in the 1970 general election
nevertheless all three major parties
supported entry so that was coming to be
one of those dangerous political
divisions arising in Britain that not
between the parties but between what you
might call the political class or the
establishment and the people so the
European issue was coming to have an
explosive potential ominously one
leading conservative politician Enoch
Powell who had supported the two
applications in 1961 and 1967 now came
out against entry and campaigned against
it with great fervor and eloquence and
he sought by combining the issues of
Europe and control of immigration to
create a new popular coalition around
the theme of British patriotism or
Nash's embattled a English
patterns more nationalism first to
restore her wounded pride and loss of
self-confidence he used to exploit
hostility to the political class
hostility has continued in some form or
other since the 1960s except perhaps for
the years when Margaret Thatcher was in
power he was the first post-war exponent
in Britain of something that we are now
very familiar with perhaps too familiar
with
namely populism and the clash between
the establishment broadly in favor of
Europe and the people moving against
Europe was to maintain it as a subject
of controversy even after entry was
secured now the Labour Party opposed
entry and proposed a referendum which
was duly held in 1975 and that led
surprisingly to many to a two-to-one
majority for staying in Europe but you
cannot in my view attribute that large
majority to enthusiasm the European
ideal it resulted in stage from two
other interrelated factors the first was
fear Britain's economic situation was
Palace inflation was 26% the highest
it's ever been
unemployment was rising and trade union
power seemed to be a serious threat to
the stability of the polity weilman
Britain's European commissioners to
Christopher Soames a former ambassador
to France and cabinet minister and
incidentally son-in-law Winston
Churchill so this is no time for Britain
to be considering leading a Christmas
Club let alone in the common market and
opponents of membership could say that
this attitude reflected an unwarranted
loss of national self-confidence a fear
that Britain could not resolve our
economic problems alone but nevertheless
for fear engendered a feeling that
leaving the community would be a leap in
the dark one poll showed that 51 percent
including one-third of those voting for
Britain to stay in the European
community believed that Britain had been
wrong to enter but 53 percent believed
that to leave would lead to an immediate
political and economic crisis the second
interrelated cause was a leadership
effect all three party leaders were in
favour of Britain joined in community so
also with those politicians of the
centre who were at that time most
popular with the public the only popular
politician opposed to entry was Enoch
Powell but he stimulated both enthusiasm
and repulsion in equal measures
enthusiasm because of his populist
nationalist
but repulsion because these attacks on
Commonwealth immigration an attack which
descended on some occasions to racist
language most of the other leaders
opposed to Europe could easily be
labeled as extremists the Communist
Party and the National Front a racialist
party the trade union leaders unpopular
since they seen unable to control
Britain's system of chaotic relations
industrial relations the Reverend Ian
Paisley leader of the fundamentalist
Protestants in Northern Ireland and shin
fain thought to be associated with
terrorists that the IRA shouldn't feign
later change its position but above all
all the left-wing of the Labour Party
led by Michael foot Tony Benn and
Barbara castle and they were the most
prominent opponents of Europe apart from
Powell all the best-known pro-european
figures had a positive rating in the
polls but all the anti European figures
except for Powell had a strongly
negative rating and one conservative
commentators said what was notable was
the extent to which the referendum was
not really about Europe at all it became
a straight left right battle with a
normal dividing line shifting further
over than in general elections because
the right wing of the Labour Party was
broadly pro-european hence the Labour
split and their discomfiture in all the
speeches I made to conservative
audiences the trump card was always
beware of been thought and castle and
the issue therefore came to be seen as
one of dividing the moderates from the
extremists once it was seen that way
those opposed to membership had little
chance and one of the leaders of the pro
Europeans after the referendum the Home
Secretary Roy Jenkins rather
incautiously declared after result was
known that voters had taken and I quote
the advice of people they were used to
following which of course leaves open
the question what would the British
people do when they ceased to take the
advice of people they were used to
following and of course that question
was answered in our second Europe
referendum in 2016 when people voted a
brexit
so the outcome of the referendum was
less than ringing endorsement of Europe
but what might be called and answered
the question of what sort of leaders do
you want to govern the country so the
leadership factor interacted with the
fear factor because there was fear not
only of the economic consequences of
Britain left but also fear of the
extremist politicians who would stand to
benefit and this again was well
expressed by Roy Jenkins in the final
rally of the Britain in Europe campaign
he said for Britain to leave Europe
would be to go into an old people's home
for fading nations I do not think it
would be a very comfortable old people's
home I do not like the look of some of
the prospective wardens and you may say
the referendum of 2016 proves him right
and what Jenkins was suggesting was the
beneficiaries would be the nationalists
of both left and right and that was also
what Harold Wilson felt he had no
particular enthusiasm for Europe but he
felt a victory of the anti Europeans
would empower the wrong kind of people
in Britain the far left and the far
right nationalist protectionist
xenophobic and backward looking to
political scientists in the book on the
referendum said it was unequivocal the
verdict but also an enthusiastic support
for membership was wise but it did not
run deep it was a vote for the status
quo but in the referendum there was a
dog that did not bark and dog which
barked very loudly in Norway in 1972 a
referendum was held in Norway on whether
Norway should join the European
community all the major parties were in
favor but Norway rejected membership and
that was primarily due to an
anti-establishment grassroots movement
against Europe which suggested that the
pro Europeans constitute a political
class which the people should oppose
in Europe there was sorry in Norway
there was a new populist leadership
sorry a new populist leadership
alternative to that of the established
politicians the obvious question is why
was there no similar movement in Britain
both Tony Benn in the Labour Party and
Enoch Powell for the Conservatives tried
to arouse it Enoch Powell wrote in a
newspaper article on Sunday before the
referendum he said in Thursday's
referendum the British people are
deciding if they want to put their shirt
on the common market and not only their
shirt but the shirt of future
generations as well as they stand
wondering and turning it over in their
minds a whole crowd of touts come up and
say to them look mates you know nothing
about all this it's much too complicated
for you to understand the town said you
must take the advice of the people who
know best the Conservative Party the big
industrialists the CBI the National
Farmers Union above all Ted Heath take
their tip do what they tell you vote to
stay in so let's look at the record of
these people who know best who continue
what will be good for Britain not just
this year or next year but for
generations to come we discover these
are the very people who have always been
wrong not one horse they of tipped has
ever won now it's a puzzle this appeal
did not prove more popular given
Britain's economic difficulties and
constant a consequent alienation from
political parties but of course it did
prove popular in the quite different
circumstances of 2016 which took place
in a period of rising distrust in
political leaders and during that
referendum a nationalist grassroots
movement led by Nigel Farage leader of
the United Kingdom Independence Party
succeeded in its aim of taking Britain
out of the European Union
now on the day after the referendum
Prime Minister Harold Wilson declared
the verdict has been given by a bigger
vote by bigger majority than has been
received by any government in any
general election it means that 14 years
of national arguments are over it means
that all those who have had reservations
about Britain's commitment should now
join wholeheartedly with our partners in
Europe and our friends everywhere note
this come our partners in Europe our
friends everywhere to meet the challenge
confronting the whole notion one
respected journalist said the day after
the referendum the Common Market issue
is settled by their unambiguous vote the
most overwhelming expression of popular
will certainly since 1931 the voters
have sold the politicians dilemmas for
them and banished the issue from the
center of British politics secession is
now politically inconceivable in this
generation but by 1979 just four years
after the referendum survey evidence
believed that both people believed by
five to two majority that membership of
the European community was harmful to
Britain in 1980 the leader of the left
in the Labour Party Tony Benn Algren of
Britain should leave the European
community without a further referendum
and that policy was adopted by Labour in
its 1983 election manifesto
so the referendum solved the issue for
only a very short period in 1975 an
advisor to the Labour Prime Minister
Harold Wilson declared that Edwin Heath
had taken the British establishment into
Europe by securing parliamentary consent
for entry but that it had needed harold
wilson to take the British people into
Europe by securing popular consent for
entry in 2016 when the second referendum
was held the British establishment
remained committed to Europe because the
leaders of all the major parties
recommended a remain vote but as the
referendum outcome showed the British
people
were no longer committed to Europe and
Wyatt came to be will be the subject of
my next lecture but by which time I mean
it's still on the statute book that we
leave on Friday at 11 o'clock British
time Continentals time 12 midnight she's
even on that matter the difference
between Britain and the Condon I imagine
it's fairly certain that a hundred
percent certain that time would be
extended but for the moment the default
position is that we leave in two days
time thank you very much thank you very
much
give a four-part question I'll cut you
off with the first part yes well this is
a huge elephant in the current
negotiations and Ireland joined the
European Union at the same time as we
did but of course is not leaning and
this is a serious problem because it's
the only part of the United Kingdom
where there's a land border with a
another country and other things being
equal if and when we leave and is
required whatever it wishes to impose
customs duties on British goods but even
more important to check for regulations
that Britain matches EU regulations in
his exports and you can see what that
means if you look at the Turkish border
with Bulgaria because turkeys in the
customs union so the duties are the same
but nevertheless there are huge queues
at the border because each European
Union member has to satisfy itself that
Turkish goods coming in meet EU
regulations which is more important now
in my view than Terry
so custom dude now since the Belfast or
Good Friday Agreement which brought
peace of the troubled area of northern
Iran which of course was largely steered
by Senator George Mitchell it's been
generally agreed though it's not
actually specific in the agreement but
the spirit of the agreement requires
that there should not be a hard border
between the two parts of the island of
Ireland and the British government has
agreed that but it follows in logic that
if Britain decides to have different
regulations or duties from the European
Union and you want to avoid a hard
border in Ireland then northern and
cannot follow the rest of Britain in
changing her duties and regulations if
we keep the same duties and regulations
it makes brexit pointless what's the
point of leaving if you keep to the same
rules so the implication is we'll have
different rules but Northern Line cannot
have those different rules now the Irish
some say have been too successful in the
negotiations of their own good because
they want a cast-iron commitment rather
than simply a British promise and that
cast and commitment is in the so called
backstop which is the main reason why do
we draw a green which has been rejected
three times so far by Parliament and the
backstop says that unless some other
method is found of keeping a free border
Northern Ireland will keep the same
customs duties as Britain and at least a
share of the same regulations sorry the
same customs use of the EU and
regulations now to resume and this isn't
a general view in Britain but this is my
view and I obviously think I'm right but
in my view that's a reason I has got a
very good deal because she's got the
whole of Britain to be to remain in the
customs union rather than just Northern
Ireland and Northern Ireland remains of
course in the UK internal market but
also in the EU internal market but
without having to adopt more than a
fraction of the regulations of that
market the e used on what it said it
would never do
they split the Four Freedoms and there
are also to be no barriers between West
and East trade from West East though if
Britain adopts different regulations
there would have to be checks in the
Irish Sea there are already it's fair to
say different regulations in northern
islands and the rest of the country on
some matters such as animal health and
agriculture and also in perhaps deeper
matters on a same-sex marriage and
abortion because the Northern Ireland
Parliament has decided not implement
same-sex marriage and abortion causes
that moans a constitutional issue go and
whether they're entitled ooh that but
that's another question and and the
Northern Ireland Irish people don't
think that threatens a human but they do
think the backstop threatens the Union
and the Conservative Party in Britain
most of whom don't I mean frankly care
one way or the other about the backstop
they take their cue from the Democratic
Unionist Party the it's a good deal and
the law of non farming and business
community as well as a majority
supporting all now and for the deal but
the largest party in known under the
fundamentalist Protestant part of the
Democratic Union part think so and the
Catholics are unrepresented because she
insane party which has all but one of
the other seats doesn't recognize
Westminster doesn't take its seat so
that is a very fundamental problem yes
and but that's I could say just this as
well the advantage of the Good Friday or
Belfast agreement made it less important
that's whether you're unionist or
nationalist because anyone in northern
and could have Irish citizenship as well
as British and of course that isn't to
be possible when we leave or rather the
Irish shall be cut off Republic for take
one example the European Union Charter
of Fundamental Rights will no longer
apply in Northern Ireland so a
nationalist and North Nile will not have
access to the same rights as someone in
the European Union including someone in
the Republic
I think if that was a hard border the
pressures for unification would increase
I think if there was no hard border they
wouldn't a poll last spring though
things may have changed in turn a poll
last spring showed only 21 percent
favored reunification and only 46
percent of the Catholic population the
favored option of the Catholic
population is power sharing devolution
of the kind brought in by the Belfast of
Good Friday Agreement and it's fair to
say the Republic would not want 1
million fundamentalist Protestants in
this gun because they've they've
overcome that I mean they've elected a
gay Indian Prime Minister and where's
Northern Ireland it's reasonable to say
I think he's in a bit of a time warp
well whether you're a Protestant or
Catholic many matters it doesn't matter
in any other part of Britain nor in the
Republic in polls since 1983 has shown a
majority of Britons don't want more
denounced remain in the United Kingdom
of Northern Ireland are and it's odd
that the up the reason I mean Northern
Ireland is unbreached because the battle
being fought in Northern Ireland is
whether they should remain British not
on the economic and social issues on the
mainland
they saw on the whole the economic
advantages and benefits geopolitical
advantage of being in a larger block and
having more influence where as I think I
said about the Empire on Monday most
people couldn't care less about having
influence or being at the top table and
they had an instinctive feeling summed
up by Antony in the comments about we we
know we could never in our bones join a
European Federation they didn't want to
be part of it and that was what came out
in the second referendum would have come
out in my view in the first if it had
been held before we joined I think then
there were been a referendum not sure we
would have joined and it's fair to say
second reading of the European
communities bill was only secured by
eight votes by a constitutional device
which is no longer possible and that
part of the reason I the problem that
Edward Heath said that the European
communities bill would be a matter of
confidence so that if Parliament didn't
vote for it he would dissolve and call
general election and that brought the
conservative rebels into line it was
passed by eight votes now two reason May
couldn't use that thanks to the
fixed-term Parliament act of 2011 which
requires a vote of confidence to be on a
specific explicit vote of confidence and
that confidence can't be brought in on
any other measure so we entered arguably
on a fairly narrow basis but the answer
your question is they saw the economic
and geopolitical advantages of being in
Europe I think I think it makes Scottish
independence less likely for this reason
that an independent Scotland when both
countries both Scotland and the rest of
the UK are in the European Union means
they're both part of the British
internal market and the European
internal market with the rest of the
country out of the European Union
Scotland be cut off from the rest of the
UK internal market furthermore she'd
have a serious problem about her
currency because if she kept the pounds
her Monetary Policy decide in London if
she had her own currency you'd require
very high interest rates with a new
currency to prevent money flowing out if
she joined the euro she would she'd be
legally required to do if she
thought really entry into the European
she would not get margaret thatcher's
rebate and she'd be legally required to
join the euro and that would mean
reducing her budget deficit from over
seven percent of GDP to 3 percent of GDP
which would make George Osborne our
austerity Chancellor look a bit like
Santa Claus really I mean it would
require vast austerity and there's a
further problem for the nationalist
movement that it split by brexit because
one-third of SNP voters supported brexit
and for them in the general election of
2017 one of the reasons SNP lost seats
they thought leaving Europe was more
important Scottish independence and
survey evidence shows if you're a brexit
ear you are less likely now to vote for
Scottish independence than if you are
not so I think Scotch in depends I feel
less likely with brexit I was struck by
your emphasis on the agricultural you
died rather than the for freedom and the
attractiveness of a bread being able to
spend his later years in the
Mediterranean and and then of course the
labor freedom - it was a source of the
yes or people have contradictory
perceptions
I remember if I can begin with an
anecdote I was once and had to get a
taxi when I was in London to catch a
train back to Oxford where I used to
work and the taxi driver asked me what I
did for a living and I said well I
thought about government and he then
said do you teach about this Europe
stuff and I said yes
did you know do you want to know what I
think about it and I said well yes of
course
I then got a long tirade about the 4th
Reich the reversal the Battle of Britain
Britain humiliated and all the rest
it and when we got near to Patti and I
said well you know given what you feel
about it what what action do you intend
to take said oh it doesn't bother me I'm
retiring soon I'm going to Spain Spain
so people have odd attitude but your
point about the young or the young are
much more sympathetic to Europe than
older people that's true whether it was
cooler in the reven absolutely right the
freedom of movement I think did not
become or never was a particularly
salient issue I think in in Britain
until people came out against it with
the immigration from Central and Eastern
Europe I think was ever seen an
advantage like one concrete advantage
people do feel about Europe almost the
only one I think is the fall in airline
prices and they benefit from that but um
people after all people went on holidays
Europe before thee before we answer to
European community how much effect it
was very difficult to point out concrete
advances to people from Europe and that
was a problem in the 2016 referendum
very difficult indeed and the the
economic argument went down badly in the
Northeast which has suffered the most
perhaps some austerity and the credit
crunch because when one politician spoke
about the benefits to GDP from being in
Europe he was met with the cry whose GDP
are you talking about yours or ours we
haven't seen any benefit so that those
those things I think did not have a
concrete effect with large masses of
people that in 2016 than you might have
predicted given the tremendous
as I understand it financial benefits
for the city and we go in international
trade how is it that that preference
didn't have more effective voice or
attraction yeah this is a very
interesting point because David Cameron
has been much criticized for his
renegotiation which did not secure the
benefit that many hoped of a possibility
of a drastic reduction in EU immigration
what he did succeed in doing was
precisely what you're mentioning which
was to protect Britain from a majority
in the eurozone and it's all interested
in this is extremely good lecture on the
website of Hartford College Oxford by
someone who I think probably knows more
about the European Union in Britain and
anyone doesn't man called Sir Ivan
Rogers who was diplomat and it's it's a
series of lecture on every Prime
Minister since Margaret Thatcher their
attitudes to Europe and Ivan Rogers
talking about Cameron he was a close
adviser Cameron and he said this was his
main worry and problem to protect
Britain against the majority of the
eurozone and he succeeded in doing that
and in particular we've also benefited I
think you know I'm over at Snyder's when
the European Court of Justice which said
it would not be constitutional to stop
us trading in euro denominated
securities even though we were not in
the euro zone of course we lose that
protection when we leave but the problem
is advances for the city and banking
particularly after credit crunch was not
a very saleable proposition to the
British I'm to say even though obviously
the bankers produce tax revenues but you
couldn't really fight the referendum by
saying if the European Union has done a
great deal for bankers and for the city
and therefore keep us in the European
you and the key issue for most people
was immigration and the the banking
issue was not one that would win mass
support so it was never mentioned in the
referendum at all for obvious reasons
[Applause]
[Music]